jetzt wollen natürlich alle wissen was ist das
ein unmittelbar bevorstehender Schadenseintritt
von katastrophischen Dimensionen aber da
hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht sich nicht
festgelegt die lassen da der Fantasie weiten
Raum und ich kenne z.B Leute die gehen davon
aus dass schon die Installierung des
dauerhaften eurorettungsschirmes ESM
eine unmittelbar bevorstehende Schadenseintritt
von katastrophischen Dimensionen auslösen wird
anderen Reich der spontane Besuch ihrer
Schwieger Eltern oder die Einführung des
egen splittings für homosexuelle Paare ich habe
ein ganz eigenes katastrophenenario also mein
Albtraum wäre ja eine schwarzgrüne Bundesregierung
unter Leitung von Angela Merkel s sie die
Vorstellung von Merkel und Rot als gespannt da
stößt für mich Alkohol an die Grenzen seiner
Möglichkeiten
wir wissen nicht genau was gemein ist wir
wissen nicht was passiert aber eines ist
sicher der Einsatz der Bundeswehr muss in jedem
einzelnen Fall von der Bundesregierung genehmigt
werden und deshalb ist es schon mal extrem
unwahrscheinlich dass die Bundeswehr jemals
gegen diejenigen zum Einsatz kommt die hier die
richtigen Schäden anrichten also dann kommen
sie ja eher zum Einsatz gegen die Menschen die
unter den Schäden die die Regierung eingerichtet
haben leiden müssen da gibt's auch wieder viele
Möglichkeiten schauen wir nach Griechenland ein
Volk das uns nur ein paar Jahre voraus ist
letzte Woche haben in Griechenland wütende
Rentner das Gesundheitsministerium gestürmt
haben sie bekommen zum Ausgleich dafür dass
man ihn die Renten um 30% gekürzt hat dürfen
die Rentner in Griechenland nämlich jetzt auch
noch ihre Medikamente selber bezahlen man
sollte alte Menschen nicht zu sehr reizen
man sollte sie nicht unterschätzen sehen Sie
wer unter Altersarmut leidet hat keine Angst
mehr sich seine Zukunft zu verbauen und
mit den Griechen wird doch jetzt nur das
ausprobiert was mit unseren rent in 20 Jahren auch
durchgeführt werden soll das ist doch ein Testfeld
da das haben wir doch gerade erfahren dürfen
dank hochkplizierter Berechnungsmethoden haben
die Experten des Arbeitsministeriums letzte Woche
herausgefunden dass selbst Normalverdiener ab dem
Jahr 2030 als Rentner unter Altersarmut leiden
W das verdanken wir übrigens der rotgrünen
Rentenreform von 2008 von 2004 Entschuldigung
2004 haben die die schon gemacht rotgrüne
Rentenreform ja damals wurde die Rente mit 7
eingeführt da haben sie alle drüber aufgeregt
aber im windschatte der Rente mit 67 haben die das
renteniveau abgesenkt auf 3% vom letzten Nettolohn
und wer konnte denn 2004 ahnen dass es den
Experten Ministerium schon 8 Jahre später gelingen
würde die geheime Formel zu finden mit deren Hilfe
man ausrechnen kann was 43 V netto bedeutet sehen
Sie prozentrecht und das ist die Königsdisziplin
in der Mathematik erst nach Anschaffung neuer
Supercomputer haben die jetzt letzte
Woche feststellen können dass 43% von
1600 € netto demement entspricht was ein hz4
Empfänger hat das ist Altersarmut dann und
dann haben sie durch intensive
Recherchen zum Teil sogar im
Internet haben sie im armensminister
herausgefunden dass selbst die Leute
die 2500 € brutto im Monat haben
auf nicht mehr als 1600 € netto
kommen wenn ich Ihnen jetzt noch sage
dass 40% aller Beschäftigten in diesem
Land 2000 € Brutto oder weniger
verdienen dann sieht man noch den
unmittelbar bevorstehenden Schadenseintritt vor
katastrophischen Dimensionen gerade zu vor sich